les fondateurs damango cacao ont
toujours travaillé dans le chocolat
ils ont même dirigé une coopérative de
producteurs de cacao en côte d'ivoire
donc pourquoi ne pas prendre leur faire
le transformer et puis payer directement
un prix juste parce que c'est ça le
problème quand on était là-bas
ils ont donc décidé il ya trois ans de
plongée de se lancer dans la fabrication
ce qui était le plus dur c'est le
financement je pense que les gens ne
nous faisait pas confiance pour le dit
terre-à-terre là on n'avait pas la tête
de pdg que les gens cherchent pour
financer on essaie de prouver d'avoir
mur arnaud petit économie comme en fait
des tables l impasse c'était vraiment
réduit au départ s'est pas fait mais où
l'entreprise familiale a finalement
obtenu un prêt de 7 mille dollars auprès
de microcrédit montréal juste avant la
période des fêtes l'an dernier la
boutique était déjà là on a juste des
corps est un peu et puis tout est rentré
dans le bushi publicité marketing pour
se faire connaître
si un prêt d'honneur c'est beaucoup basé
sur la confiance qu'on assure le
promoteur de projets sur la personne les
prêts de microcrédit montréal vont de
cinq cent vingt mille dollars pour les
entrepreneurs et de 500 à 15000 pour les
professionnels immigrants -2 5% libéré
on offre aussi un accompagnement
personnalisé pour les personnes qui
veulent soit se lancer en affaires en
entrepreneuriat ou qui veulent avoir
mise à niveau de leurs compétences et si
au québec je vais lui parlé en tamoul
l'organisme a reçu 2 millions du
ministère du travail le printemps
dernier ce qui porte son capital
disponible à 3 millions unis on a un
beau problème au nahd capitale après t
on à un chèche
que plus de gens nous connaissent et on
peut les aider
mais il a des goûts a immigré au québec
il ya trois ans quand je suis arrivé ici
je commence à apprendre le français
ça m'a pris un an environ pour arriver
un niveau avancé
titulaire d'un baccalauréat en
architecture obtenu en syrie il a aussi
dû suivre plusieurs autres formations
pour que ses compétences soient
reconnues un long processus qui l'a
financé en partie auprès de microcrédit
montréal et m'ont donné des contacts des
gens qui travaillent dans mon domaine
je les ai appelés on a jasé ça m'a aidé
financièrement je pourrais dire
mentalement c'est halo et depuis le
début où il travaille enfin comme
stagiaire dans une firme d'architecturé
je vais devenir architecte dans deux ans
je fais maintenant sur le chemin j'ai
trouvé l'emploi que je cherchais
chez à mango cacao si le ton est à
l'optimisme dans cinq ans il faudrait qu
ai je suis fan de pollution pour la fois
quatre fois plus grande que ce que nous
avons ici et on sait que on va y arriver
l'entreprise a réussi finalement à
recevoir d'autres financements 75
millions $ de famille sort et de la bdc
et c'est marie claude morin radio canada
montréal
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit